we don't know how long Val has been the
CIA director because John Walker didn't
really seem to know she was and the CIA
director is a president-nominated and
Senate approved very public figure well
the average person might not know who
the CIA director is someone like John
Walker would know but either way this
means that Val's recruitment of Walker
and recruitment of Yelena belova to kill
Hawkeye all of these things had the full
weight of the US government behind it
and now since Val is going to be leading
the Thunderbolts the Thunderbolts is
going to be a much more public Squad of
killers I think this is definitely going
to tie into secret Invasion and Captain
America New World Order and yeah
Thunderbolts and Val just shot at the
top of my list as scroll suspicious and
Everett Ross right behind her
[Music]